so what do you think um
i don't love the sash but it's fine i'm
just gonna get it what that's the first
one you tried on i once saw you look at
54 different accordion folders and not
buy any of them due to weak tabs i file
hard i need strong tabs i just don't
want to take up any more time
your break's not even a quarter done
i'll stay another 10 minutes you'll stay
until i dismiss you irene music
now spin
all units attempt at 10 30 charlie
bodega on smith purpose heading east on
baltic that's us we're on baltic
oh crap that was him
hey
[Music]
[Music]
stay down damn sarge maybe i do like the
sash oh go room 103.
what are we going to do it's still
frozen in the middle well then turn up
the tip it's already at 500 it's maxed
out then that's the [ __ ]
okay geez i thought you said you
searched the entire first floor i did i
even checked the ceiling for clingers
hey who's that guy from cyber sergeant
knox we've been talking computers all
day pretty technical stuff i kept up his
face is really familiar i can't place
him
[Music]
it's empty and there's nothing plugged
into the internet port knock said he got
a nos ping i mean nasa's don't just ping
themselves guys jake stop you're not
fooling anybody you don't know anything
about computers
oh my god
you're right i'm not fooling anybody i
always fool jakey you're my computer boy
no no no no i don't know anything about
computers none of us do and knox could
tell that so he knew that we wouldn't
catch on if he just made stuff up what
if the reason we can't find the hacker
is because there is no hacker but why
would knox lie about that what if he
doesn't actually care what's on the
lakme servers maybe his real goal is to
just trick holt into erasing all the
servers he might just be trying to
delete some evidence
so you think he's a criminal oh my god
we have to go right now
i know how i know knox he's the guy from
the security footage in the avery street
murder you sure yes he shaved his beard
but it's definitely him you see amy how
is she great she just got lunch double
helping of spinach baby's gonna love
that folic acid you are so strange all
right this is her first time eating in
the dining hall where she chooses to sit
is very important
no good she's headed towards that table
of hot blonde girls
wait a minute
no
they're nazis the hotties are nazis
they're hotzies swerve amy swerve
good good
okay and
all right sitting alone bold choice bold
choice
oh good here comes maura hey court says
i hear you can smuggle and crap from
outside noise it's working that's right
baby what do you want what i want is for
you to back the hell off
because i'm the only store in this
prison well well i didn't see your name
on the outside of the prison unless your
name is texas state penitentiary comma
spring valley unit
what are you looking at we got a problem
whoa cool the killer
i just wanted to say good job on beating
the crap out of that doctor
oh
thanks i like you you got balls
maybe you should come work for me
i could use a bruiser on my crew
i'm not a bruiser
i'm a psycho even better
yes
i did it
i am the greatest athlete in the world
no
wow oh where's all
oh there he is there he is i did it i
did it
good god
are you al the janitor
nope i'm your worst nightmare
amy santiago oh
no
i don't understand what is happening
allow me to explain
amy and i were ahead of you the whole
time
no you weren't part of this get back
over to the loser's side loser all right
worth a shot so how did you pull it off
well it all started when i went to tell
jake how badly hurt my feelings and he
yelled at my breasts oh boy i am not
going to come off well in this story
nope remember when you set off the witch
he made captain holt flinch which was
weird since his door was closed but not
weird since he actually heard it over a
bug he planted at your desk it was in an
old muffin that you never threw in the
trash that's why people throw away
garbage how are we together
anyway i tapped into the bud's frequency
so i had ears on jake i needed to know
what holt was up to that's where
hitchcock came in
i masterminded the entire plan you did
one small thing and i had to explain it
to you like 45 times he left a tiny
crack in the blind so i could read the
captain's lips sharon and your kids will
distract jake they'll be here at 9 30
sharp my waffle xylophone on the cheese
man what my lip reading is not flawless
now that i knew your plan it was simple
to disrupt while scully gracefully moved
the witch i got into character
holt triggered the witch which brought
jake into the room and i threw the crown
in the trash can exactly as i planned
then i sent you all here placed an out
of order sign on the perfectly
functional elevator made you all walk up
31 flights of stairs and vomit twice
actually it was four times if you count
all the stairwell stuff you thought i
was just holt's lackey and you thought i
was just jake's girlfriend well i'm my
own person capable of making my own
decisions and i decided to humiliate you
both well
you did and
it was awesome
one last question where's the crown oh
it's at shaw's bar the official site of
my coronation
all hail the crown of destiny
and all hail she who wears it amy
santiago
the
queen queen of the nine-nine
i believe there's something else you
both need to say gladly
amy santiago is an amazing detective
genius
okay partner let's bang this out should
we grab a cup of coffee bounce some
theories off each other i solved it
already oh
then should we grab a cup of coffee you
could tell me what you found out no we
can do it here the fires were set by
richard wilcox a firefighter who was
first on the scene at all three fires
okay uh now we just have to work
backwards figure out why he's up for a
promotion and wanted to look like a hero
yep but
how are we gonna find this bastard after
all these years he owns a store i have
the address okay
i could drive no
you don't know where we're going
but if you'd like a cup of coffee
there's an old bakery in that
neighborhood the coffee beer is terrible
but i would enjoy the nostalgia
i love terrible coffee
now let's put away richard wilcox at no
good punk he's 86 years old
you don't outgrow punk sir
he's hearing on the move
all
gotcha
sergio we've been waiting seven years to
say this sergio mindar you're under
arrest that's why i owe you apostrophe
re can't believe you caught me well
believe it we're an amazing team
we're the sleuth sisters
damn straight we are
lame stay out of sergio
uh
you